I'm a feminist I am a feminist I'm a
feminist I'm a feminist I'm a feminist
I'm a feminist
how do we feel about women having rights
yes
really cool thing awesome the more the
merrier what would you say is the most
feminist thing about you yourself I
believe women should be paid the same
across the board not just white women
but women of color you begin to be a
person of color and not believe that
women should have the same rights as I
as a black person so that's why I'm a
feminist and I believe that women should
feminism is about women being equal
period yeah yeah for me it's just like
uplifting women voices for women's
rights I think like a good thing for us
to start like how do you guys Define
feminism like an advocacy for equity in
the institutions for women right not
just in the economy in society but also
in government and other positions of
power like I I looked over and I saw
like not to hate anyone that wears
running shoes but like I saw the running
shoes and I just assumed I think that's
just like a Trope that like a lot of
like anti-feminist like right Wingers
dress more for Comfort than style so
it's just a stereotype that I was
playing on I think supporting women in
all areas is so Reproductive Rights
you know work pay rights all that type
of stuff and I think being a voice for
the ones that can't speak up because I
find myself getting into arguments with
people because I'm like I will like
really like have this conversation with
you so I think just always supporting
them no matter what my eye immediately
went to Emma I was like that very much
could be a conservative woman in this
group just based on her outfit it was a
great outfit she looked great I guess my
view on feminism is that it goes beyond
women as well like we include trans
people in there and like by uplifting
women and trans people you then see a
better society and environment for like
men and like other people you said
something about agreeing with women no
matter what they do like I fully
disagree I feel like feminism you have
to hold women accountable like there are
women like JK Rowling who likes leaving
and spearheading and transphobia
movement in the UK and you can't like
hide behind feminism when you were
literally hurting women oh totally I I
feel like that was just like a broad
statement when you say supporting women
I think for me when I was in a workplace
run by men I feel like couldn't stand up
to like the plate and step up and really
like talk about how I'm feeling because
I would just get shut down so I think
like in those situations I mean like if
there's like no one that can like
support Someone Like You should support
them and educate them in a way what do
you usually do in instances where you're
like shut down by a man in power you
could say well nowadays it's different
okay if I was saying a few years ago
which is kind of like
rebuttal and just go about and do what
they want me to do but now I have a
voice and I will kind of there's not
like something equal I will just point
out the fact that hey that's not fair
like it's just a thing of being strong
and powerful I think and so what do men
do in those situations women a lot of
time aren't taking it seriously by men
in the patriarchy I think it's really
important for us to like let our voices
be heard and uplift their voices keep
each other in check yeah allow a
platform for women to speak let their
voices be heard because that's the most
effective way to dismantle ignorance his
speech seemed very practiced or thought
out it didn't seem natural I think also
just putting women in leadership at my
work all of leadership is all women yeah
and I feel the safest there compared to
other workplaces where I've been kind of
like duking it out with the boss man
kind of thing my bosses are all women
too I will say that traditionally I have
had issues with women being my boss but
strong women as I've grown as no but as
I've grown and educationally yeah now
that I know women's roles and so I agree
with you with that assessment that women
in leadership it is just something about
it right yeah I feel safer too and I
grew up with the family of Brothers It's
always having to like fight to say
anything and also a Hispanic household
so a lot of times it's like the woman's
here to serve and all of that and having
like grown up with that kind of like
mindset made me go the complete opposite
you know what I'm saying
if you like this episode and you want to
see more make sure to like this video
And subscribe to our Channel now let's
figure out who the mole is
[Music]
I think when people tend to use a lot of
dictionary definitions they were either
studying up on it I mean you don't have
to go Merriam-Webster on us and trying
to explain it
you know Emma she's a little too
comfortable and uncomfortable at the
same time if that makes any sense
[Applause]
uh
good luck everybody thanks man thank you
thank you appreciate it yeah I had a
weird hunch that it was coming I'm very
formal so um that can make it seem like
I'm kind of more nervous or more uh
studied rehearsed I want to expand on
what you said
I'm wondering how you guys feel about
trans women in women's sports I'm down
for it I'm a trans person myself and I
think the root of that problem tends to
stem like with like we're protecting
children but you can't say you're
protecting children if you're kicking
out trans children it is like a
non-starter and it distracts from I
think more imperative issues with like
the Banning of gender affirming care and
like housing and that's one of my
biggest problems with like modern day
feminism is that it tends to Center Rich
CIS hit white women and I'm like that's
weird how do you feel well yeah I just
want to see because I was wondering I
don't know how the casting I don't know
if there's any turfs or swerfs in the
group because I don't determine that to
be feminism because like for me trans
women are women so we should be
protecting all women not just CIS women
I have no problem with about sports and
stuff but I also don't want to silence
the JK rowlings of the world because I
believe in democracy and I believe to
know your enemy you need I want them to
speak I don't that that's how they used
to do things that he'll do that's what
the KKK does they hide their face sure I
want to know who they are and I want
them to speak freely so you know who the
enemy is sometimes they get a little
violent though when it turns people I
mean I think I understand what you mean
like you you agree with Free Speech but
not to the point where it should like
restrict someone else like you don't you
don't know but I definitely want the JK
rowlings and the margin Taylor greens
the talk I want them to talk because
they sound so stupid but you also want
to know who they are and then what what
do you think you haven't said anything
um I'm kind of like I'm I'm not against
it I'm not like so much
I feel like I don't have a clear answer
because in like with like kids
like when you talk about kids doing it I
don't think with children I think
everyone should like everyone's the same
they have the same strengths and
everything like that but I think in like
professional sporting situations I and I
might need to educate myself more on
this so this might be like what I need
to come out of today and do but I I
think trans women still have like more
strength than women like
but even saying that like they're women
but I feel like it's not even exactly
she compared trans women to women uh
referring to CIS women as the women and
like kind of them referring to trans
women as not women I was like oh that
might it might be her
um like they have an advantage you would
say yeah like a slight Advantage so you
might be against it maybe I mean see I
don't want to say that though because
then I'm not really supporting all women
okay but um so if it's professional
let's be honest if you're good you're
good I think if a transgender woman went
up to play tennis against Serena
Williams and it's a transgender woman
she's probably more than likely lose
yeah
so so when we talk about strength and
stuff sometimes it's just skill yeah so
I think for sure like there's some that
like the absolutely even but I think in
very limited areas of sport then like
there might be a slight Advantage but
things get like tennis and soccer like
those type of things are all skill a lot
of people get mad at trans women in
sports when in reality majority of trans
women that compete in sports currently
aren't doing that well it's not like
there's like a crazy big Advantage
um a lot of them are on hormones for
like a long time like it's even gone to
the point where we're trying to make a
CIS women who have high testosterone way
lower so it's a regulated thing so I
wouldn't worry too much about it yeah
right right well a lot of times let's
just be what we call it what it is it's
just it's about people's religion it's
about your ideology your religion yeah
yeah and which again you know has no
place in they're shielding their hate
yeah because Jesus said so
foreign
not so much what he was saying or
stating but the fact that he was just
giving me information overload I was
like you kind of distracting me from
what we were actually discussing
when the question of sports came up Emma
immediately kind of withdrew and also
like as a trans person I'm just
immediately like
that's suspicious to me
good luck thank you
I could have easily just agreed and
played the game and got to the end but I
know this is a game but I think it's
also a game of topics and conversations
so I I'm not mad about getting voted out
and how it went
if you think the mole could still be in
the box and you want to continue playing
the game please raise your hand
I think we say I was still about to
continue if you guys want to end it I'm
cool with ending it the light turns
green that means you have voted out the
mole and you all win the lights turn red
that means the mole is still in the box
and you lose
three that's good
to
[Music]
step forward in three
two
one
step right up okay yeah
yeah there is no mole yeah
my bad
I'm so sorry
First Impressions right
so here's the thing the mole actually
never showed up but we still wanted you
all to play the game
[Music]
I was first
we were done case closed and I feel like
I was probably too quick to judge I
think it's an interesting social
experiment to see infighting even Within
These groups getting a bunch of
feminists in the room and seeing who
points to another one and say I don't
think you're a feminist extremely
interesting to me and also extremely
interesting that I was the first one out
I felt some hesitation about coming on
the show just because I didn't want to
come off as someone as a man accusing
women of not being feminists because
it's a really weird position to be in
I'm like is it corny to go on a show and
be like a male feminist but like no it
shouldn't be I think walking away from
this I really want to educate myself
more on transgender women that's when we
go blind you cannot be about democracy
equality freedom and all this stuff and
then sit up here and have barriers in
place for somebody because of their
gender I think it's just our job as
people to be accepting and loving and
just say I'm here I'm here to listen
[Laughter]